It turns out that this problem is actually remarkably similar to
the skier problem we did in the previous problem set,
and we're going to have to use a lot of geometry to help us get through this.
We're first going to try and solve for what your speed is when you just jump of the swing,
and to know that, we're going to have to know how much potential energy you started with,
and to know how much potential energy you had, we're going to have to know
what your height was above the ground.
And doing a little trigonometry here, I find that the maximum height
achieved by the swinger is 5-4cos 45°, and this turns out to be 2.17 m.
And using the equation for gravitational potential energy,
I find that my original potential energy is 1302 J.
I know that the original potential energy of this value of 1302 J
is going to be exactly equal to my final potential energy plus my final kinetic energy.
Let's start by solving for the final potential energy.
Once again doing a little more trigonometry, I find that my final height above the ground is 1.54 m,
and using this height, I get a final potential energy of 924 J.
Now from this equation, I know that the final kinetic energy
is just going to be equal to the difference in the two potential energies,
which is equal to 378 J and using the equation for kinetic energy,
I get that the final speed is equal to 3.55 m/s.
Alright, now that I know my speed when I'm jumping off the swing,
it should be pretty easy to figure out how far I go.
Alright, if I do a little geometry here, I see that the angle that the velocity that make the horizontal
is exactly 30°, the angle of the pendulum.
And now that I know that this angle is 30°, I can solve for the
x and y components of velocity as shown here.
Now I can use this kinematic equations here
to solve for the time t when I finally reached the ground.
And note that this value of Δy is is not equal to 1 m when I jumped off the swing,
it's actually equal to this value hf and plugging in my numbers here
and then using the quadratic equation to solve for t, I find that t = -0.405 s or t = 0.761 s.
And just like in the ski jumping problem, we know that it's actually this value for time we care about.
This one we don't care about, so now we know it take me 0.761 s
after I jumped off of the swing to hit the ground.
And now let's figure out how much I move along the ground in this time.
To calculate how far away from the swing I land, I'm going to use this kinematic equation here.
And this time there is no acceleration in the x direction,
and plugging in my numbers I find that I've landed 2.34 m away from
where I jumped off the swing--great work!